who to you is the most fascinating
serial killer
of the of the true crime
yeah uh things that you've explored i
think well ted bundy's way up there uh i
think uh charles manson
um uh
yeah and is another um have you seen on
ted bunny because i find him super
fascinating have you seen uh there's a
lot of movies on him
extremely
wicked shockingly even and vile
it's a retelling of his life from the
perspective of his girl long term
girlfriend no i have not seen that one
which ties together a lot of our
conversation so i it's probably my
favorite one a lot of people say it's
the best movie on ted bondi you should
definitely watch it i will uh i
recommend it to others but it's from a
perspective
uh
of the relationship and it's just
one of the really powerful
windows into a serial killer that i saw
there
is that from the perspective of the
relationship you can have just this
healthy looking relationship yeah
there's some fights and so on but the
usual dating and all that kind of stuff
was all there so all the murders he was
doing he had a long
term girlfriend throughout all of that
and also throughout all of that i'll try
not to give away in case you don't know
the story throughout all that she stood
by side
she refused to believe everything that
was happening yeah until until
um
you know the very end of course it
shifts in the very end and that's a
fascinating shift of the
the breaking of the the illusion but
it's really fascinating that you can
have those two things
that
you yeah well i think that
part of it is we
have these stereotypes that we expect
people like serial killers to be these
um
ugly um drooling creatures that are sort
of uh
evil all the time
uh and so um
that's why even like you had um i don't
know if this is
if i'm remembering this correctly but
like stalin who killed you know millions
of people apparently like
loved his kids and loved his family and
people so so we have that's part of the
complication uh the complexity of human
nature in human psychology is we we
don't have just this one
you know this one property that
dictates how we behave in all
circumstances
yeah the devil
is going to be charismatic
that's why um
that's one of the things i've learned
about just looking at evil people
looking at jeffrey epstein
who seemed to have hoodwinked quite a
lot of people yes yeah that's another
that's another fascinating case yeah not
that he wasn't a serial killer but a
serial sexual predator
and a lot of people
i
know and respect
didn't
see
the evil yeah
and
so i never met the guy
but it's like
are you guys oblivious like what what
was there must have been something and
from everything i see is purely just
charisma
it's it's the it's the smoking mirrors
yeah that uh he was very charming
psychopath
yeah and but i i think every psychopath
to be effective has to be charming yeah
the successful ones yeah
yeah successful psychopaths
oh
yeah and that was i mean ted bundy was
one he was a good-looking guy um
intelligent and
could turn on the charm
and and then had this evil
is there something interesting to be
said that i think a large percentage of
the fan base like i've seen numbers like
80 plus of the fan base for true crime
shows is women
is there is there some psychology behind
that i haven't seen that i'm not aware
if a sex difference that i'm not aware
of that you should
i mean i i've heard that in a lot of
places so i wonder if there's some um
there's something about troop crime
maybe because it's um
just just like sexual kinks for for men
develop early on for
the cues
maybe for women there's the cues of the
threat of violence
the attentiveness to violence it
develops early on and so and therefore
fascination with violence well well i
think that i mean one thing is that
well with serial killers specifically i
don't know if this is true of true crime
in general but
serial killers like you you find like um
[Music]
a lot of people well a lot of women fall
in love with them uh or you know even if
they're they're jailed for serial
killing
and i think one of the
features of it is that
um it it parasitizes or hijacks
status mechanisms in that a key cue to
status
is the attention structure that is the
high status people are the people to
whom the most people pay the most
attention and so serial killers garner a
lot of attention and
even though for
evil deeds um it's still attention
so i think that that hijacking of our
status allocation adaptations is partly
responsible for that